ونحييكم متابعينا من جديد اعلنت الولايات
المتحده والفلبين عن خطط لتوسيع الوجود
العسكري الامريكي في الدوله الواقعه بجنوب
شرق اسيا مع السماح الى الولايات المتحده
بالتواجد في اربع قواعد عسكريه اخرى وذلك
في اطار سعيهما لردع الاجراءات الصينيه
المتزايده تجاه تايوان وفي بحر الصين
الجنوبي المتنازعي عليه الاتفاق تم التوصل
اليه خلال زياره وزاره الدفاع الامريكي
الى البلاد لاجراء محادثات حول نشر القوات
والاسلحه الامريكيه في المزيد من قواعد
الجيش الفلبيني وفي بيان مشتركين قال
الجانبان انهما قرر تسريع التنفيذ الكامل
لما يسمى باتفاقيه التعاون الدفاعي المعزز
والتي تهدف الى دعم التدريب المشترك وفي
اطار الاتفاق خصصت الولايات المتحده 82 او
82 مليون دولار لتحسين البنيه التحتيه
خمسه مواقع حاليا متضمنه في الاتفاقيات
التعاون الدفاعي المعزز الصين بالمقابل
ردت من خلال خارجيتها واعتبرت فتح الفلبين
اراضيها امام التواجد العسكري الامريكي
يضر بالاستقرار الاقليمي ويزيد من
التوترات
لطالما اعتقدت الصين باستمرار ان التعاون
الدفاعي والامني بين الدول يجب ان يفضي
الى السلام والاستقرار الاقليميين ويجب ان
لا يستهدف او يضر مصالح اطراف اخرى تواصل
الولايات المتحده تعزيز انتشار جيشها في
المنطقه الامر الذي يزيد التوتر ويضر
بالسلام والاستقرار الاقليميين يجب على
دول المنطقه توخل اليقظه وتجنب التعرض
للمخاطر من قبل الولايات المتحده
هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا الصحفيين الدرونج
اهلا بك ومن واشنطن الدكتور عقيل عباس
الخبير في شؤون السياسيه اهلا بكم ضيفاي
اسمح لي ان ابدا معك دكتور عقيل دكتور
عقيل لافهم من حضرتك كيف تقرا اولا هذه
هذا التوسع
الدفاعي او توسع التعاون الدفاعي بين
الفلبين والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
ظل حديث الفلبين عن انها تحاول ان تعيد
علاقاتها طبيعيه مع الصين خاصه في فتره
رئيس الحالي اللي شهدت فترته اضطرابات مع
الصين توسيع
المشاركه الدفاعيه او
التحالف الدفاعي بمزيد من القواعد ما الذي
يعني ذلك
شكرا لك على هذه الاستضافه
الكريم السياق الاوسع لهذا هو طلب الدول
الحليفه الصديقه للولايات المتحده في
منطقه بحر الصين الجنوبي نحن نتحدث عن عده
بلدان كوريا الجنوبيه اليابان تايلاند حتى
اندونيسيا ومن ضمنها الفلبين بزياده
الوجود العسكري الامريكي وتايوان طبعا
بشكل اساسي
زياده الوجود العسكري الامريكي زياده
الدوريات الامريكيه زياده التعاون
العسكريه الامريكي قلقا من الطين يعني
هناك سياسات تقلق بلدان هذه المنطقه من
الصين جزء منها مرتبط بالاصطياد المبالغ
به
الادعاء عوده جزر ومناطق لها صناعه جزر في
المنطقه استخدام يعني اقتراب السفن
الصينيه دخولها من المياه الاقليميه لبعض
الدول يعني هناك تشبه الاجماع من حلفاء
الولايات المتحده انه هذا السلوك الصيني
مقلق وطالبوا الدوله الامريكيه بالقيام
بشيء ما وهذا جزء من خطوات قامت بها
الولايات المتحده من ضمنها صفقه مع تايوان
مؤخرا الموضوع عموما يتمحور حول التايوان
حول تايوان ولكن سيد نادر من الاخطر اكثر
على الطرف الاخر لانه مع توسيع هذه
الشراكه الدفاعيه يقول مسؤولون فلبيون
باننا نحاول ان نتصدى للخطر في اشاره ربما
للصين فمن الاخطر هل هذا التحالف هو
الاخطر ربما على الصين
احلام ومرحبا بكم
اولا يعني
كل
ما يسمى بتحديدات الصينيه هي يعني ليس
يعني
موجودا واقعيا وهناك
المحاوله من جانب الولايات المتحده
يعني تكبير هذا النظريه التحديدات الصينيه
وذلك من اجل التشكيل
التحالفات
يعني من اجل احتواء تدهور الصين
فيمكن ان نرى يعني
من خلال التعاون والتطور العلاقات بين
الصين ودول الجوار يعني يمكن حل المشاكل
في ما بين هذه الدول ولكن بسبب التدخلات
الخارجيه خارج
المنطقه بوجود الولايات المتحده
يعني
وخاصه تعزيزي التواجد
القوات الامريكيه في هذا هذه المنطقه يعني
لا يساهم في
يعني
باي درجه سيد نادر يعني حضرتك تقول بان
للصين القدره على حل خلافاتها مع دول
الجوار
بطريقه اسهل ان لم يكن هناك تدخل امريكي
اليوم هذا الوجود الامريكي الذي ياخذ في
التوسع شيء فشيئ
وقريب من الصين هل سيعطل وباي شكل تتحدث
على امكانيه تصعيد بمستوى معين كيف
يزيد
التوترات بين
في المنطقه ولا في
السلام الاستقرار
كما قلت
[موسيقى]
مثلا مثل الصين قد اتفق الدوله على حل
جميع الخلافات بينهما بتربص الميه وسن
ايضا تتماسك بالطريقه السلميه فلذلك بدون
يمكن ان نرى في عقود الماضيه بدون
التدخلات الولايات المتحده في الصين قد
اتفقت مع دول المعنيه ودول الصيام حول حل
الخلافات في البحر الصين الجنوبي دكتور
عقيل هل نفهم بان واشنطن تلعب لعبه
التاجيش بانها في كل مره
محمد ساكبه زيت على النار لتاجيش الوضع
اكثر
يعني لا اعتقد هذا هذه طلبات الدول تلك
المنطقه يعني كررت حقيقه كانت تشتكي من
الانضواء الامريكي او ما يسمى الانسحاب
الامريكي في عهد الرئيس ترامب وكانت تضغط
على الاداره الجديده كي تظهر اهتمامها
بهذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه مهمه نحن نتحدث
عن سته تريليونات من التجاره العالميه تمر
بتلك المنطقه حيويه اساسيه وهناك قلق
متصاعد من السلوك الصيني يعني استخدام
القوات العسكريه حل التهديد بخصوص تايوان
الطيران الذي يخرق الاجواء البلدان
المختلفه في المنطقه السفن التي تدخل في
المياه الاقليميه كلها تفسرها دول المنطقه
على انه هذا شكل من اشكال التنمر العسكري
والسياسي الص نحن نتحدث عن بضع الدول
كلها او معظمها دول ديمقراطيه منتخب
رؤساءها ويشعرون انهم يحتاجون الى الحمايه
الامريكيه وعلى هذا الاساس كان الدخول
الامريكي في هذه المنطقه او زياده الدخول
فيها
ما رايك في هذا الكلام فيما حضرتك تقول
بانه للصين القدره على حل مشاكلها مع دول
الجوار بطريقه سلسه ضيف يقول لك بانه
بدايه طايوان هي من استدعت واشنطن
لمساعدتها وفيلبين مدت كذلك
يعني يدها لو واشنطن لتوسيع هذا الحضور
على اراضيها وبالتالي يبدو بان للصين
مشاكل كبيره في تسويه هذه
الملفات مع دول الجوار مما استدعى حضور
واشنطن
كنت اريد ان اوضح شيئا بالنسبه الى
جزء لا يتجزا من الاراضي الصينيه وهي ليست
دوله يعني مستقله في هي منطقه تابعوا
للصين لذلك كلما تفعله الصين هي فقط
استخدام حقها في اراضيها
اما الدول المنطقه مثل الفلبين والجوار
الاخرى
ليس لديها اي نيه العدائيه اتجاهها ويمكن
ان نرى خلال السنوات الماضيه هناك
كبير بين سن
وفلبين وهناك
زياده التعاون فداله الصين اكبر شركه
تجاري
فلبين فهناك يعني فوز المشتركه والتعامل
مثمر بين البلدين
بدون التدخلات الدول الخارجه هذه المنطقه
فلذلك يعني
كل يعني
المخاوف من الصين فليس هي يعني امر على
الواقع بل هي يعني
كيف نقول التصورات او صنع ذلك من دول
الخارج هذه المنطقه
دكتور عقيل لنسلم جدلا بدقه ما طرحه الضيف
بان واشنطن هي التي تحاول في كل مره ان
تحرك الامور لاثاره بعض
الاضطرابات في مناطق تهمها طيب نفكر بصوت
عالي
ونضع بعين الاعتبار هذه المتغيرات التي
يعيش العالم الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
واشنطن التي تدير هذه الحرب مساحه التعبير
وتتمدد ليس فقط في الفلبين ولكن في مناطق
اخرى في ش اسيا هل يمكن القول بان واشنطن
تحضر لشيء ماش شرق اسيا كذلك
يعني ليس من مصادر الولايات المتحده فتح
جبهه الجديده لها في مكان اخر فيما هي
منهمكه يعني في حرب صعبه في اوكرانيا يعني
هذا اولا فقد ليس من الحكمه وربما يعني
هناك تفسير شائع في الولايات المتحده
وربما بين بلدان تلك المنطقه ايضا انه هو
الصين تستفيد من الانشغال الامريكي في
اوكرانيا وتحاول ان تجرب حظها ولذلك يعني
هناك هذا السلوك الذي تعتبره دول المنطقه
عدائيا يعني نحن نتحدث عن
الفيتنام عن الفلبين عن كوريا الجنوبيه عن
اليابان عن تايلاند كل هذه الدول تقول
باشكال مختلفه ان هناك ما يبدو سلوكا
عدائيا صينيا يفسر على انه اختبار لقدره
واشنطن او ربما الاستفاده من غيابها عن
المنطقه لكنه الولايات المتحده والعاده
الدكتور عقيل نتحدث عن قواعد وهناك
مسؤولون يقولون بان الخامسه كذلك تدرس الى
جانب الحضور الامريكي فيما قبل كذلك في
الفلبين هل تعتقد بان كل هذا التوسع هو
فقط
لدعم التعاون هو فقط لمحاوله الضغط لاكثر
البعض يقول بانه كان هناك استعداد لشيء ما
هو الطمنه الاصدقاء والحلفاء هذه
الاتفاقيه يعني في 2014
اتفاقيه تحسين الدفاع بين الفلبين
والولايات المتحده وهي لا تتضمن قواعد
دائما الدستور الفلبينيه يمنع وجود قواعد
عسكريه اجنبيه وانما زياره القوات
الامريكيه مجيء القوات الامريكيه بين فتره
واخرى وضع معدات وضع بنيه تحتيه بالتعاون
مع القوات العاليه دكتور عقيل ليس هناك
فرق كبير بين القواعد يعني كبير اقصد
مناحيه استخدامها بين القواعد الدائمه
والقواعد التي
اتخذتها وتتمركز فيها القوات الامريكيه
القواعد الدائمه هي قطعه ارض تصبح
تمتلكها بشكل من الاشكال
وقادره ان تنشئ فيها ما ارادت ولكن
القواعد كذلك المحدوده بالزمن ستستخدمها
بما يتوافق مع مصالحها فالاستخدام واحد
بالتاكيد الولايات المتحده تستخدم هذه على
اساس مصالحها لكن هذه المصالح متسقه مع
مصالح البلدان التي دعت الولايات المتحده
الى المزيد من التعاون العسكري يعني هنا
جزء الصيني انه لا يتوقف عده رغبه هذه
البلدان وهذه البلدان ذات سياده كما هي
الصندات سياده لها الحق بتقرير كيفيه
الدفاع عن نفسها وتقرير الخطر والتعاطي
معها كما هو الحقل الصين ونحن نتحدث عن
عده بلدان تقول نفس الشيء في سياقات
مختلفه في سياقات دبلوماسيه واحيانا في
سياقات علنيه خجوله بالتالي لا يمكن اعطاء
اولويه لوجهه النظر الصينيه على
التقليل من قيمه وجهه نظر الدول الاخرى
المستقله ذات السياده سيبقى الموضوع
للمتابعه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عقيل عباس
الخبير في شؤون السياسيه وشكرا لضيفه صحفي
نادر رونك شكرا لكما